En retrospectiva,
en relación a ese primer verano en Roma,
veo los cambios que se han dado en estos últimos seis años,
es una transformación absoluta.
Es un mundo nuevo para la transición de datos al mundo humanitario.
Es emocionante. Es inspirador.
Pero aún no estamos allí.
Y agárrense bien, ejecutivos,
porque voy a estar poniendo a compañías
en el banquillo de los acusados para que cumplan con su papel.
Mis experiencias en Roma prueban
que aprovechando los datos se pueden salvar vidas.
Bueno, no ese primer intento,
pero eventualmente lo logramos.
Les describiré la imagen.
Imaginen que tienen que planificar desayuno, almuerzo y cena
para 500 000 personas,
y que solo cuentan con cierto presupuesto para hacerlo,
digamos USD 6,5 millones al mes.
Bueno, ¿qué deberían hacer? ¿Cuál es la mejor manera de manejarlo?
¿Se debería comprar arroz, trigo, garbanzos, aceite?
¿Cuánto?
Suena simple. No lo es.
Tienen 30 alimentos diferentes, y tiene que elegir cinco de ellos.
Ya serían más de 140 000 combinaciones diferentes.
Luego, para cada tipo de comida que se elija,
necesitan decidir cuánto comprar,
de dónde se obtendrá,
dónde se almacenará,
cuánto tiempo tomará llevarla hasta allí.
Necesitarán analizar todas las rutas de transporte distintas también.
Ya esas serían más de 900 millones de opciones.
Si consideraran cada opción por un segundo nada más,
les llevaría más de 28 años estudiarlas todas.
900 millones de opciones.
Por lo tanto, creamos una herramienta que permite a los que toman las decisiones
procesar las 900 millones de opciones
en cuestión de días.
Resultó ser increíblemente exitosa.
En una operación en Irak,
nos ahorramos 17 % de los costos,
lo cual significa que hubo la capacidad de alimentar a otras 80 000 personas.
Todo es gracias al uso de complejos sistemas de datos y modelado.
Pero no lo hicimos solos.
El equipo con el que trabajé en Roma, ellos eran únicos.
Creyeron en la colaboración.
Incluyeron al mundo académico.
Incluyeron a compañías.
Y si de verdad queremos hacer un gran cambio en grandes problemas como el hambre mundial,
necesitaremos que todos sean parte.
Necesitamos que la gente que maneja los datos en organizaciones humanitarias
sean los líderes del proceso,
y que organicen los compromisos correctos y precisos
con académicos, con gobiernos.
Y aquí resalta un grupo que no ha sido aprovechado de la manera que debería.
¿Lo han adivinado? Las compañías.
Las compañías tienen un gran papel para arreglar los grandes problemas del mundo.
Yo he estado en el sector privado durante dos años hasta ahora.
He visto lo que las compañías pueden hacer, y lo que las compañías no están haciendo.
y creo que hay tres formas principales para poder cubrir ese vacío:
Donando información, donando científicos de decisión
y donando tecnología para recolectar nuevas fuentes de información.
Esto se llama filantropía de datos,
y es el futuro de la responsabilidad social corporativa.
Además, tiene sentido desde una perspectiva de negocios.
Las compañías de hoy en día recolectan montañas de datos,
por lo que comenzar a donar esos datos es lo primero que pueden hacer.
Algunas compañías ya lo están haciendo.
Piensen, por ejemplo, en una compañía de telecomunicaciones.
Ellos liberaron sus datos en Senegal y Costa de Marfil
y los investigadores descubrieron
que si se analiza los patrones en los pings a las torres de servicio móvil,
se podrá ver hacia dónde está viajando la gente.
Y eso le puede decir cosas como
hacia dónde se puede propagar la malaria, y realizar predicciones en base a eso.
O, por ejemplo, una innovadora compañía de satélites.
Ellos liberaron sus datos y los donaron,
y con esa información se puede registrar
cómo las sequías impactan a la producción de comida.
Con eso se pueden activar fondos de ayuda antes de que ocurra una crisis.
Este es un gran comienzo.
Hay conocimientos importantes atrapados entre los datos de las compañías.
Y sí, se necesita tener cuidado.
Se debe respetar el tema de privacidad, por ejemplo, al anonimizar los datos.
Pero incluso si se abren todas las puertas,
e incluso si todas las compañías donaran sus datos
a académicos, a ONGs, a organizaciones humanitarias,
no sería suficiente para aprovechar el impacto total de los datos
para fines humanitarios.
¿Por qué?
Para desbloquear estos conocimientos en los datos, necesitará científicos de decisión.
Los científicos de decisión son personas como yo.
Ellos toman los datos, los depuran,
los transforman y los colocan dentro de un algoritmo útil
para tomar la mejor decisión y enfrentar la necesidad del negocio del momento.
En el mundo de la ayuda humanitaria existen muy pocos científicos de decisión.
La mayoría de ellos trabajan para compañías.
Por lo tanto, eso es lo segundo que pueden hacer las compañías.
Además de donar sus datos,
necesitarán donar a sus científicos de decisión.
Ahora, las compañías dirán "¡Ah! No nos quiten a nuestros científicos de decisión.
Necesitamos cada segundo de su tiempo".
Pero hay una manera.
Si una compañía fuera a donar un bloque del tiempo de un científico de decisión,
en realidad, tendría más sentido extender ese bloque de tiempo
por un período largo de tiempo, digamos, por ejemplo, cinco años.
Esto significaría quizás un par de horas al mes,
que no sería gran pérdida para una compañía,
pero que permitiría algo muy importante: alianzas a largo plazo.
Las alianzas a largo plazo permiten forjar relaciones,
ir conociendo los datos, de verdad entenderlos
y comenzar a entender las necesidades y retos
que la organización humanitaria está enfrentando.
En Roma, en el Programa Mundial de Alimentos, esto nos tomó cinco años,
cinco años.
Esos primeros tres años, bien, no había forma de evitarlos.
Luego hubo dos años después de eso para refinar e implementar la herramienta,
como en las operaciones en Irak y otros países.
No considero que ese sea un plazo poco realista
en lo que respecta a usar datos para hacer cambios operacionales.
Es una inversión. Requiere paciencia.
Pero los tipos de resultados que pueden ser producidos son incuestionables.
En nuestro caso, se trató de alimentar a decenas de miles de personas.
Entonces, hemos donado datos, hemos donado científicos de decisión,
y hay una tercera forma en la que pueden ayudar las compañías:
donando tecnología para captar nuevas fuentes de datos.
Verán, hay muchas cosas sobre las que no tenemos datos.
Ahora mismo, hay refugiados sirios desbordándose sobre Grecia,
y en la agencia de refugiados de la ONU no tienen un respiro.
El sistema actual para rastrear a la gente es con papel y lápiz,
lo cual significa que
cuando una madre y sus cinco hijos entran en un campamento,
la central queda básicamente ciega en este momento.
Todo eso va a cambiar en las próximas semanas,
gracias a la colaboración del sector privado.
Va a haber un nuevo sistema basado en un paquete con tecnología de rastreo,
donado a la compañía de logística para la que trabajo.
Con este nuevo sistema habrá un rastro de datos,
por lo que se podrá conocer el momento exacto
en el que esa madre y sus hijos entran al campamento.
E incluso, se podrá saber y ella tendrá provisiones
para este mes y el siguiente.
La visibilidad de la información impulsa a la eficiencia.
Para las compañías, el uso de la tecnología para recolectar datos importantes,
es el pan nuestro de cada día.
Ellos lo han estado haciendo por años,
y eso ha llevado a importantes mejoras de la eficiencia operacional.
Solo trate de imaginar a su compañía de refrescos favorita
tratando de planificar su inventario
sin saber cuántas botellas hay en los estantes.
Es absurdo.
Los datos llevan a mejores decisiones.
Ahora, si uno está representando a una compañía,
y es pragmático y no solo idealista,
quizás esté pensando: "Ok, todo esto está muy bien, Mallory,
pero, ¿por qué querría estar involucrado?"
Bueno, para empezar, más allá de la buena publicidad,
la ayuda humanitaria es un sector de USD 24 000 millones,
y hay más de 5000 millones de personas, quizás sus próximos clientes,
que viven en el mundo en vías de desarrollo.
Luego, las compañías que se involucran en la filantropía de datos
están descubriendo nuevos conocimientos atrapados en su información.
Consideren, por ejemplo, a una compañía de tarjetas de crédito
que ha abierto un centro
que funciona como una sede para académicos, ONGs y gobiernos,
todos trabajando juntos.
Ellos buscan información en las lecturas de tarjetas de crédito
y usan esos datos para conocer más sobre cómo los hogares en la India
viven, trabajan, ganan y gastan.
Para el mundo humanitario, esto brinda información
sobre cómo se puede sacar a la gente de la pobreza.
Pero para las compañías, esto brinda conocimientos sobre los clientes
y clientes potenciales en la India.
Todos ganan aquí.
En mi caso, lo que me parece emocionante de la filantropía de datos
-- donar datos, donar científicos de decisión y donar tecnología --
es lo que importa para jóvenes profesionales como yo
que decidimos trabajar en compañías.
Lo estudios muestran que para la próxima generación de la fuerza laboral
es importante que su trabajo genere un impacto mayor.
Queremos hacer la diferencia,
y con la filantropía de datos,
las compañías pueden ayudar a involucrar y a retener a sus científicos de decisión.
Y eso es un asunto importante para una profesión que está en alta demanda.
La filantropía de datos tiene sentido comercialmente,
y también puede impulsar una revolución en el mundo humanitario.
Si coordinamos nuestra planificación y logística
a lo largo de las facetas más importantes de la operación humanitaria,
podríamos alimentar, vestir y acoger a otros cientos de miles de personas,
y las compañías necesitan dar el paso y tomar el papel que sé que pueden tomar
para hacer realidad esa revolución.
Quizás hayan escuchado la expresión "alimento para el cerebro".
Bueno, esto es, literalmente, usar el cerebro para alimentar.
Finalmente se trata de la idea correcta en el momento correcto.
(Risas)
Très magnifique.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)